it is
my great joy and privilege to introduce
bill
can we please welcome bill huang up here
please welcome bill wong
the question of who is bill wong is one
that everyone seems to be asking right
now
here's someone who really was not on
anyone's radar and yet he was ranking
among the world's wealthiest people
but now bill huang and what has happened
to his firm will likely go down in 2021
as one of the most remarkable stories of
the year not just because of the rapid
rise but the even faster implosion
he was an outsized influence in
financial markets but almost nobody had
ever heard his name and nobody had ever
heard the name of his firm arcagos
capital management
[Music]
this whole situation to me is like a
string of are you effing kidding me how
could that many prime brokers be so dumb
as to lever up one guy all on the same
stocks it really is every bank for
themselves at this point it was this one
family office that caused so much mayhem
it was bill huang's personal fortune
which he had built into a firm that was
pretty sizable in the market one way to
measure this fiasco is by adding up bill
wong's losses 20 billion dollars to the
10 billion dollars that the banks have
lost in total you've got 30 billion
dollars wiped out in the space of a week
investors on wall street lose money all
the time but archagos is almost unique
in financial history because of the size
of the positions that a single
individual accumulated and the speed
with which it unraveled this is one of
the most spectacular failures in modern
financial history
no individual has lost so much money so
quickly
my entry point to the archago story was
goldman sachs
very early on goldman emerged as a
seller
of almost 10 billion dollars of
securities on a friday dumping stock
onto the market in a way that was
exceedingly rare almost unprecedented
and any time i see the name goldman
sachs i'm always curious and so i went
down the goldman sachs rabbit hole and
found out some interesting details about
goldman's relationship with this firm
archagos and the man behind it bill wong
it really goes back to the final days of
march when you had this frenzy of block
trades hitting the market there were a
bunch of big chinese tech names u.s
media conglomerates and across the board
we were seeing the stocks falling
everyone in the market was trying to
figure out what the heck was going on
bill huang's background is very
different from anyone else that you've
heard of at the pinnacle of wall street
here is someone who grew up in a family
of modest means in south korea his
father was a pastor he was assigned to a
church in las vegas and will wang and
his family moved to the united states
when he was about 18 years old in 1982
within a few months of his arrival his
father passed away he used to work night
shifts at mcdonald's
and it was on his mother's insistence
that he go to college that he attended
ucla and subsequently earned a business
degree at carnegie mellon
back in the late 80s and early 90s it
wasn't so easy to get to wall street if
you were an immigrant he couldn't get a
job at goldman sachs he couldn't get a
job at morgan stanley yet his dream
was to come to new york city
so bill wong ended up taking a job at
hyundai securities and he turned out to
be a very good security salesman at
hyundai securities because he caught the
attention of julian robertson
julian robertson is the famous hedge
fund manager who founded the powerhouse
firm tiger management
and so bill wong became a tiger cub
the term tiger cub is used to describe
the
former employees disciples if you like
of julian robertson
anyone who sort of worked with julian
robertson had great success under him
and then was able to spin out and start
their own hedge fund or their own
investing firm came to be known as the
tiger cup
julian robertson ceded bill huang's
hedge fund and that's what gave tiger
asia its start bill wong's hedge fund
tiger asia was a very very successful
firm at one point it managed 10 billion
dollars
[Music]
but tiger asia crossed the line between
aggressive and illegal in 2012
securities regulators across the world
accused the firm of insider trading bill
huang had to plead guilty on behalf of
his hedge fund for wire fraud
he had to shut down tiger asia
but after he settled that and he shut
down his hedge fund
he started our cagos archagos is what's
known as a family office
it's an investment firm managing money
for an individual in this case bill wong
but instead of trying to start a new
hedge fund with the taint of a
securities violation he would take the
money that he had something north of 200
million dollars at the time and invest
his own money hire his own analysts do
his own work and make money that way
instead of having to make money for
clients and he was incredibly successful
he did a couple of things that worked
very well in his favor the first was he
invested in tech stocks
he rode the decade-long boom in firms
like amazon linkedin expedia netflix
facebook google
the other thing he did increasingly was
use borrowed money on wall street it's
called leverage he had borrowed a lot of
money and that meant his gains were
exacerbated and he then plowed them all
back into the same bets that by the end
of it you had someone who had taken a
fortune that started at a little over
200 million and in under seven years had
taken it to over 20 billion dollars
jesus
says
i'm the bread of life
if you come to me you'll never be hungry
again
bill huang was someone who was devoted
to his church who was focused on the
idea of spreading the word of christ
your people will be my people and your
god
will be
my god
he believed that by investing in these
companies he was advancing society on
behalf of god
my company
does a little bit
of our part bringing the fair price to
google stock price is it important to
god absolutely in some ways he was able
to find a justification for all his
wages to stick with them and to double
down on them irrespective of not being
mindful of the hedges he would have had
to have in place
he talks about this idea that everyone
else on wall street is burdened by the
thought of being powerful and having too
much money and he says he doesn't feel
it he says he's not afraid of death or
money he says i am just following god's
word and that is truly a fearless way to
invest
he didn't live large he didn't have a
penthouse apartment in new york city he
didn't have a fancy vacation home in the
hamptons he lived a relatively modest
life in suburban new jersey drove a
hyundai suv
this is really a grown-up version of
someone you will see on wall street bets
or robin hood this is someone who really
likes a stock or two or three would bet
on it and stick with it and not worry
about anything else there was no
complicated investing strategy here god
has clearly showed us
what money does in a positive way here
someone was completely driven by faith
who completely believed in the right of
what he was doing and allowed that to
become the driving force
not allowing any sort of distraction for
self-doubt
or even second thought in what he was
doing and that proved to be his undoing
[Music]
on the afternoon of march 22nd viacom
cbs announced a stock and convertible
bond sale the company wanted to raise
three billion dollars here was a stock
bill huang was really invested in he had
a huge outsized position in it every
time the stock moved up he would throw
more money into it and the stock would
keep going up and up and up and up
[Music]
instead of helping the stock
this stock sale hurt the stock terribly
the following day viacom cbs went down
nine percent on the wednesday it went
down 23
with the stock declining that far that
fast it forced a margin call a margin
call is a demand by wall street firms
for more collateral if you've borrowed
so much money that all of a sudden
there's no equity left after a stock
drops that quickly the firm will demand
more collateral if bill wong has no
money left or refuses to put up any
further money the dealing firm takes
over his position
the wall street dealers pleaded with
bill wong to sell some stock so that he
would at least survive he might take
some losses from 20 billion dollars he
might go down to 10 or perhaps even less
but he would live to fight another day
and bill wong refused
if it was just one bank making the
demand that might have been fine
[Music]
when all his banks made the same demand
you knew you had a problem and really
that was the beginning of the end for
bill huang
any fortune built on borrowed money is
standing on a shaky base a gust of wind
could threaten it in the case of bill
huang he was facing down a hurricane
names that he had plowed billions of
dollars into were moving against him and
he never had any effective hedge the
banks had started to panic they had
loaned him a lot of money and they were
demanding that he needs to post a lot
more cash otherwise they would have to
terminate the agreement and liquidate
his portfolio
he did not have enough spare cash lying
around and they did have to cut their
ties and liquidate his entire portfolio
in the end bill huang lost it all
but not just that the banks that had
lent him money they also lost quite the
fortune think of archaegos as a burning
building
and its bank lenders as the people
trapped inside
the moment one of those people one of
those banks makes a break for the exit
all hell breaks loose yet someone like
credit suites losing 5.5 billion dollars
namura in japan losing in excess of 2.5
billion dollars and yet you had banks
like goldman sachs wells fargo deutsche
bank who seem to have escaped this
largely unscathed in total you've got 30
billion dollars wiped out in the space
of a week
the last person out of the burning
building is the one who always sustains
the greatest damage
in this case that was credit swiss
[Music]
it was only in the days after that that
we were able to piece together what
really happened and the root cause
behind it all
a whale is wall street slang for someone
who wields outsized influence in
financial markets
it's like looking at the ocean and
seeing a glass-like surface
but under the surface is this enormous
enormous creature
that's what bill wong was like to wall
street
he was an invisible whale
almost nobody had ever heard his name
and nobody had ever heard the name of
his firm
and that all goes back to this financial
instrument that he used which was swaps
now what are swaps
swaps are a type of derivative that
allows you to effectively remain
invisible instead of your name showing
up in securities filings it's the name
of the firm you're dealing with that
shows up so it could be credit suisse it
could be goldman sachs it could be
deutsche bank it's the banks that
appeared as the stockholders and he was
the one benefiting from the move in the
price of the stock and that would allow
him to remain anonymous through that
process
the people familiar with archagos both
its accounts and its positions spoke to
us on the condition of anonymity because
they weren't authorized to comment
we don't really have a good idea what
bill wong has left we know he's got a
suburban home in new jersey we know he
drove a hyundai
presumably he's still got that but we're
not aware of any other investments that
he may have had but with so little
financial disclosure available it's very
difficult for anybody to have a really
solid idea of of what bill wong has left
after this collapse
[Music]
the only saving grace perhaps from this
entire fiasco is that we really haven't
seen a systemic problem we really
haven't seen
banks on mars pull back risk expose more
hedge funds to the problems and see more
dominoes falling
however what is the lesson that we all
learn from what happened to our chaos so
far the prime brokerage business hadn't
been top of mind for regulators hadn't
been top of mind for politicians but
you've had both entities jumping into
the fray for now demanding answers for
now trying to figure out how stable and
sound the system was
you don't want these invisible whales
out there who have great outsized
holdings in stock and no one knows about
it so the same disclosure rules that
apply for hedge funds will possibly be
the case going forward for family
offices
bill wong has undoubtedly suffered some
reputational damage as a result of the
collapse of his firm and it's hard not
to see the irony in this story on the
one hand you've got bill wong the pillar
of his church community and on the other
you have this guy who's making wildly
speculative bets with enormous amounts
of borrowed money
it's so hard to bring those two people
together into the same person which is
why we keep
asking ourselves
why
[Music]
you